what's going on guys
this mother lode of comic book movie
news is insane Marvel just unleashed
phase three on us and we are reveling in
it and we have an awesome panel here to
break it down first
you know I'm from the schmoes know check
them out on YouTube and AMC movie talk
Kristian harloff but I don't care what
the vision is Marvel DC this is an
awesome time to get comfortable he is an
actor comedian friend of the show Mike
Carlson hi hell I am psyched and he is
one of the creators of the awesome
comics and comics sacks car you know I'm
gonna take you one step further
Christian I think the Marvel movies are
actually a good time to be a movie fan
so I want to start off real quick um
Mike and Christian you were both at the
event yesterday you saw it all go down
what was it like in there we were it was
like Hall H you were at Comic Con and we
were just like we were cheering like two
words dr. strange we'd be like yes yes
we know I knew that was happening but
that doesn't matter because I'm so
excited to be in this room right now so
let's talk about this slate so first
kicking it off a movie that we expected
Captain America Civil War first they
showed us seen Joss Whedon was in the
audience
they brought a scene from The Avengers
and it was a scene between Chris Evans
Robert Downey jr. and was a scene in The
Avengers age of Ultron where they're
having this kind of back and forth and
they're already not agreeing on stuff
and you see and I'm watching it I'm
going they're showing this for a reason
and who comes on the stage Downey and
Evans it was awesome the back and forth
and that entire videos on schmoes know
if you want to see it so next
chronologically comes Doctor Strange
hasn't appeared in a movie yet is
getting his own solo movie tell us a
little bit about Doctor Strange well
he's uh he was an arrogant surgeon who
only cared about money and then he was a
house yes there's a lot like how
essential items yeah yeah it was acts he
had an injury like house and then he
went and found the ancient one and he
gave him all these sort of mystical
powers and taught him the ways he
basically like he freaks out because he
breaks his hands in a car accident and
he goes to any possible cure he can get
so like one of the like crazy crackpot
cures as he goes this guy called the
ancient one he's like oh fix my hands
and they's really magical and he teaches
him real magic and he becomes the
sorcerer supreme strange was name
dropped in Winter Soldier blues band is
Stephen strange anyone who's the threat
do we know is this Doctor Strange movie
going to be an origin story I would
assume it's going to be especially from
where here at Kara phii's say yesterday
because it's not a property that non
comic-book fans really know I think I
read a report that said they're not
doing origin stories for these next
movies okay I could be wrong about it
but I think they were said they were
just gonna like start variable that but
um I guess part of the reason though
they had to introduce they gotta get
strange out there they gotta get Black
Panther out there which we'll touch on
in a moment is they need more characters
to go at it in civil wars you can just
use the handful that we have all right
but they also have to go pass because
the question is and we'll get to what
how phase three is going to end because
it's kind of end dramatically and big
and and that Marvel's not gonna stop
making movies so the question is going
to be where do you go after phase three
and in order to do that you have to
build characters and if you're building
Black Panther or Captain Marvel over
talk we'll talk about soon and all these
characters eventually the Tony Stark's
and Rogers they're all going to have to
either split off or someone's going to
die something's got to happen because
otherwise it gets boring and repetitive
and we need new Avengers and new teams
so this makes sense to introduce new
people okay so next chronologically
comes guardians - they killed it with
guardians the biggest surprise Money
Train of the summer and the entire
creative team is back for the next one
if I'm relieved so yeah which should
chew liver again hopefully the next
door' movie was dropped yesterday thor
ragnarok
what's Ragnarok it's like the end of all
things means apocalypse right yeah you
know it's it's driven it's taken
directly from the actual myths
Loki initiates like the apocalypse for
the Asgardians and it pulls everything
into it gotcha so uh what you're saying
is we're going to see some more Loki
yeah oh yeah they said it then Loki gets
bigger applause than Thor does beep I
know by Sivaji 11 days after this we'll
probably reset Thor - from what he said
it makes me feel like they're going to
do Thor's had a number of different
incarnations where he's like been sort
of connected to and not connected to a
scar this may see Thor stuck on earth
possibly with a limited power set or
something basically that we're going to
get a different Thor when it
that will be relevant to the the final
films to the infinity or next black
panther very cool that we're getting a
superhero of color in this new phase
tell me a little bit about black panther
and his origins we're probably gonna see
a different origin here because the
original black panther is the king of an
african nation and it has super science
technology it seems like now what Conda
is going to be a secret country or like
some sort of you know very isolated
Enclave and the key connection there is
that what Conda is where vibranium comes
from which is where cash was kept in old
and it's probably what's Ultron Ultron
that probably draws us to Wakanda which
is why it's there but he'll and he's a
fighting king yeah and at the event the
actor playing him was introduced
chadwick boseman if you have not seen
him and get on up okay this dude is a
serious actor he transforms himself the
guy is an up-and-coming star and I think
he's going to be forever in everyone's
mind as black man yeah this guy can
drive a movie again yeah a couple of
more new characters new groups to
introduce Captain Marvel tell us a
little bit about Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers used to be Miss Marvel and in
the comics that's the person that rogue
got her flying and her super-strength
from because she touched hurt for too
long okay Wow and and Carol Danvers
takes her powers and her name from
Captain Marvel who was a Kree superhero
that basically they're in the same cave
at the same time and some device
explodes called the psycho magnetron and
it basically joins their DNA so she
gains all of his powers I don't think
that original Captain Marvel is gonna
exist so she'll probably get her powers
a different way but she will be and he
said this on stage the most powerful
character in the Marvel Universe man
it's the Superman equivalent characters
any thoughts on how we think she's gonna
be infused into what the universe is
in the comics right now she's like
gotten like very space centric
adventures she hangs out with the
guardians of the galaxy okay so I mean
there's a second movie coming up there's
a decent chance maybe she wants to you
know mix it up with them next up the the
comic the group that I was least
familiar with in the announcements the
Inhumans it's been teased for a while
another one that's been teased and
rumored and Vin Diesel was teasing it
for a bit other one was teasing it I
know nothing about those people the
Inhumans are an offshoot of humanity
that was created by the Kree the cool
thing about them is that
because they've been like sort of
genetically engineered they can subject
themselves to this as they call the tie
Geryon mist and it gives you all power
you're born is regular human and then
like on your 18th birthday or whatever
you go into the Tajiri and mist and you
gain superpowers and then once you do
you fall into their society and a
specific role how do we see them fitting
into that's no idea in the comics they
had they just had a like a bunch of new
and humans start to appear I feel like
we could have some sort of an event that
all of a sudden turns everybody into an
inhuman not everybody some people into
you in humans but we could have a ton of
them let's talk about the mega infinity
war so we have seen throughout the
movies how powerful these individual
Infinity stones are might tell me a
little bit about the power that the
Infinity Gauntlet possesses oh how can I
tell you about all the power ever
Thanos gets this essentially it's a
glove and it's the power glove it's an
NES power glow that's an NES power do so
some rocks into it so he becomes godlike
yeah right well you're ready even when
you watch guardians of the galaxy I love
Santos just for when Ronan's yelling at
him and he's just kind of like smirk
sounds like Perry go see what you can do
you probably get blown up oh you did and
so it's just he just has this thing
about him now do we think it's gonna be
a cliffhanger or do we think it's gonna
be - Stan yeah here's the thing that I
made up in my head last night that I
want it to be yes I want it to end
obviously on a down note there are other
Donald's has just got this is boot
around their throats yeah Captain Marvel
has to do something in space that will
help the fight so that spins out into
another movie she goes and does
something then comes back to earth in
humans also there's something going on
that they have to take care of then it
could be like a day then we're like back
to part 2 so it could be all one story
that's a theory I made oh yeah that's
the Mike Carlson theory that's floating
around the internet now so you as a fan
let's go down line what are you most
excited to see the culmination Avengers
the part 1 and part 2 where where we all
lead up all these great films we're
going to get in the future and then the
ending of finalizing Thanos in the game
Mike there's going to be a scene with
Robert Downey jr. and Rocket Raccoon and
they're going to be quipping at each
other they're called trading barbs we're
going to love it
we're gonna say more more MORE and
that's what I'm looking forward to I
have a totally different but now I might
have to go with yours that really is the
best thing ever but yeah I actually
gotta get everything I need out of Civil
War
my favorite scene in the Avengers was
the Shakespeare in the Park fight where
Thor and Captain America and Iron
Hollywood's well you make a whole movie
of that I will watch it and that's the
first of all these films so I already
win and then the rest of its just
framing what are you most excited about
what in this Marvel announcement are you
just going bananas over let us know in
the comments section below
the best comment we are going to send
you a screen junkies t-shirt I want to
thank you guys for dropping serious
knowledge today Christian of our loft
check him out on Mose know on YouTube
and AMC movie talk Mike Carlson thank
you for being here again sax car thank
you for coming in and dropping major
nerd knowledge and I want to thank you
for watching screen junkies I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter thanks
again for watching bye bye it looked
like this lots of those things people
remember bigger and scarier than they
were like the opening of Twilight Zone
one my favorite horror film opening yeah
sure you know want to see something
really scary